today I want to talk about
the basic education
and the theme is going to be that it's a
necessary but not sufficient strategy
for education for the future we're all
familiar with the basic education model
we start in kindergarten and go through
grade school through high school
hopefully go on to a two or four-year
college and maybe even two graduate
school then we enter the labor force and
we start our working career after we
complete our education
well that model no longer works today we
have to think about lifelong learning
because technologies are changing the
job market is changing in unpredictable
ways and new ways of working are going
to continue to come along they're going
to require us to refresh our skills as
this graph shows the evidence is clear
high school dropouts are really doomed
to a lifetime of poverty wages on
average they are in about $24,000 a year
high school graduates get to about
$34,000 a year and college graduates get
to about $55,000 a year average income
so the key lesson of this graph is by
all means everyone must finish high
school and hopefully go beyond that but
you could say the same thing for high
school graduation college still pays off
this graph shows the difference in
median earnings of high school and
college graduates and you'll see that
it's been growing over time that both
for men and for women the gap between
the high school and the college degree
earnings has grown and so there's
increasing returns to college even given
the increased cost of college this graph
shows that adjusting for the increased
cost that gap is still growing and the
increase in returns to college
particularly since around 1980 have been
growing by very very large numbers and
so the message here is that yes college
is expensive but we've got to be careful
not to underestimate its value at the
same time it's important to recognize
that there's wide variation
in the earnings of college graduates so
it's very important to be careful to
choose when where and what kind of
organization what kind of institution
you choose to get your education and
ending your education and then entering
the workforce was a model that worked in
the past but is not going to work in the
future
so let's look more carefully at how we
are going to move throughout model of
lifelong learning in the future
you